[music playing]
Eric, Jared, congratulations.
Your weapons were strong
enough to propel you
into this final round of
competition, which means you're
both one step closer to the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and that
check for $10,000.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to create an iconic blade
from history, the Hunga Munga.
The term Hunga Munga refers to
a variety of Central African
throwing knives,
all of which feature
a series of double-edged iron
blades attached to a rawhide
handle.
The Hunga Munga was
not only formidable
in hand-to-hand combat but
could be thrown from a distance,
with some reports
claiming it had a throwing
range of up to 250 feet.
As armor was not used
often in Central Africa,
this type of throwing iron
was particularly devastating.
Hunga Munga was
often very valuable
and could be traded for goods.
The Hunga Munga was
also wielded by Buffy
Summers in the cult series,
"Buffy the Vampire Slayer."
First thing I
thought was [bleep]..
[laughs] I was not
expecting that.
Your weapon must fall within
the following parameters.
It must have a sharpened
head, crescent blade,
a spear, and a spike.
You must also include a handle
arm with a sharpened spike
above the handle.
It must be an effective, working
version of that deadly weapon.
However, we want you
to make something
that's unique that could
only come from your forge.
I'm looking forward to
decking this Hunga Munga out,
and putting my own signature
style in the details
and decorative work.
I'm trying to think
of how complicated
this thing will be to build.
It's complicated forging.
You will have five
days at your home
forge to complete
this challenge.
At the end of those
five days, you
will return and present
your finished weapons
to our panel of expert judges.
Only after they've subjected
your weapons to a series
of brutal tests will
they declare one of you
the "Forged in Fire"
champion who walks away
with that check for 10 grand.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
First day, really happy
to be back in my shop.
I have never made anything
even remotely like this before.
This is like a cross
between a sword,
boomerang, chakram, battle axe.
I gotta plan this out.
I'm gonna start with
this blade, then
pull this off from
the side, and then
start working the spike in.
This is a wild build.
[hammering]
[whirring]
JARED (VOICEOVER): So I'm
gonna have to heat this all up.
I'm gonna have to
drive this down.
It's almost a chess game.
I've got to think like five
moves ahead on this thing,
because if I screw
up once, it could
completely ruin the
piece of steel I got
and I got to start over.
[hammering]
This chunk here hopefully will
turn into my sickle blade here.
[sawing]
Maybe if I heat this area here,
swinging this out of the way
here.
[whirring]
[hammering]
I'm gonna push
that up into there.
Then I can push this around.
[whirring]
[hammering]
That's--
[clanging]
[inaudible] point's
going to be it.
[music playing]
[whirring]
ERIC (VOICEOVER):
It's day three.
I'm a little sore,
but I got the blade
profiled, forged out, and feel
great about my blade design.
Bam.
Still think it looks like
something from Whoville.
Now it's time for
the heat treat.
Everything leading up to
this point is just critical.
[rumbling]
All right, here we go.
Beautiful.
[music playing]
ERIC (VOICEOVER):
I was totally giddy
when I got it out of
the quench and I just
want to give it a test throw.
This thing is definitely
a lethal weapon.
It's not a prop.
It's definitely something
you don't want thrown at you.
It will stick.
[laughs]
[music playing]
JARED (VOICEOVER): Plan for
today is finish up the pommel,
carve in the sunbeam,
and then wrap the handle.
This was a really difficult
piece to forge and to create.
Maybe I should have some worries
going into the final round,
but I really don't.
I did the best I can do.
I'm super confident
in what I made.
And just see how it pans out.
I think this thing's gonna
just perform spectacularly.
[scraping]
My competitor-- he'd better
really bring his A-game,
because I'm feeling good.
Bladesmiths, to see how
sharp your blades are,
I will take your weapon and I
will test the crescent-shaped
blade and the spear.
If your blade is sharp,
it should lacerate cleanly
through this stretched leather.
Jared, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I am.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Well, Jared, your handle
wrap feels good to the hand.
The blade of your
crescent and your spear
right there is sharp
enough to lacerate cleanly
through the
stretched-out leather.
It will cut.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
Eric, you're up.
Ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
OK, Eric.
Nice grip.
Your crescent edge over
here, at the initial start,
not so sharp.
But once you got it
going, it lacerated.
Your spear edge, same thing.
It started off here.
But once it got
going, it lacerated.
Not all edges are as
sharp as the other,
but it is sharp enough to cut.
My concern was this design that
you have over here for this--
being that it's
a weapon that you
move around, having that pointed
at me is never a good idea.
Right.
Otherwise, though,
this blade will cut.
Good job.
Thanks.
ERIC (VOICEOVER): That
first slice skipped across
and it got to a part
where it was sharper.
Blade's not performing well.
I'm quite disappointed.
Bladesmiths, this
is a kill test.
The Hunga Munga was a weapon
with multiple configurations
of blades on top of a blade.
To see how lethal your weapon
is according to its design,
I will take your weapon and I
will deliver multiple strikes
on this ballistics dummy.
Let's see how lethal
your blade is.
Jared, you're up first.
You ready?
Definitely.
[music playing]
[squishing]
[laughs] It looks
like he's bleeding.
Well, Jared, every facet
and design of your blade
will definitely do damage.
Your crescent edge nicely
lacerated through the tip
on that hook and gutted
whatever was in there.
For your small
blade, I had to angle
a little bit because there's
not much space over there.
But, as you can see, if you
work it according to its design,
you can jab right into it.
And, of course, your spear
tip crushed through the bones
and into the heart.
This, sir, will kill.
Great job.
Thank you.
Eric, you're up next.
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[squishing]
[crunching]
[slapping]
Didn't get that
laceration there.
Hm.
OK, Eric.
Your spike right there?
It's in a good
position because I
can easily go in
there without worrying
about this getting in the way.
So we come to the spear tip.
That went through all the way,
broke bone, and into the heart.
Your weapon will kill.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
Next up is the strength test.
For that, I'll pass
you on to Dave.
Gentlemen, we've seen that
the Hunga Munga can be used
as a close-quartered weapon,
but it was specifically
designed to be thrown.
So to test the strength
of your weapon,
I'm going to throw it three
times into our wooden target
here.
If your heat treat is sound,
the structural integrity
of your weapon should
hold up to the impact.
If not, we could have
a catastrophic failure.
Jared, you're up first.
Ready.
All right.
Safeties.
[music playing]
[tapping]
ALL: Nice.
Damn.
It split that log.
[laughs] That's cool.
[clanging]
Ooh.
Nice.
No catastrophic failure.
I'm happy it didn't break.
[grunts] [bleep]
Nah, just a scratch.
Boop.
Really happy with my design.
Final throw, it
sticks in beautifully.
Well, as you can see,
this is a dangerous weapon
all the way around.
It feels really
good in the hand.
All that foward weight
makes it rotate beautifully.
Your edge is still
a razor blade.
I mean, once this
thing's traveling,
I don't want to be on
the other side of it.
Your cord wrap made it
really nice to throw.
Well-executed.
Thank you.
Eric, your turn.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
[bang]
[thump]
Oh my.
There you go.
[bang]
Nice.
Well, Eric, this feels
pretty good in the hand.
I like all this detail
you did down in here.
I mean, it doesn't
affect the throw.
It doesn't affect the strength.
But still, it's there.
Dug in nicely.
When I hit up here, it
kind of bounced out.
It scored up the wood.
It would have taken a man out.
The other two throws
dug in nicely.
Looks to me like your
edges held up fine.
That's still all
right and tight.
Nicely done, Eric.
Thank you.
Eric, Jared, you've
both done fantastic
work on your Hunga Mungas.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
[music playing]
Jared, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Eric, your Hunga Munga
did not make the cut.
Dave will explain.
Eric, the addition of
that spike on the back
was a question mark.
But in the end, it came
down to the overall finish
and construction and
the way it did not
perform in the sharpness test.
That's why we gotta let you go.
Eric, please surrender
your Hunga Munga.
ERIC (VOICEOVER): The judges'
feedback, I agree completely.
I have no regrets whatsoever.
ERIC (VOICEOVER): I came here
to prove that I could do it,
that I could overcome a task
that was seemingly impossible.
I may not be the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
but I can only go up from here.
Jared, congratulations.
You are our new "Forged in
Fire" champion and will be
receiving a check for $10,000.
How do you feel?
[applause]
I don't know what
to say, really.
It's kind of a shock right now.
That's straight-up
the prettiest
and most terrifying thing
we've ever had on the show.
Thank you.
I mean, the
combination of the two.
I want it-- that's
how I feel about it.
And I don't feel like that
about a lot of knives.
But that's a cool piece.
Thank you.
JARED (VOICEOVER): I won.
Still kind of settling in.
[laughs] 10 grand is
going into the shop.
There'll probably be
a little trip involved
for my fiance and myself.
Boy, having the title of
"Forged in Fire" champion,
it's going to definitely
be a game-changer.